If you were confused at all about what exactly
happens the ending of Season 2, then stick
around to the end of this video.
Sponsored by CryptTV.
Welcome back to Things You Missed -- the year
is 1930, and not more than 11 seconds into
season 2, we've already got a guy going on
a rampage against his family.
Why is this guy so angry?
And what does this all have to do with the
rest of the season, taking place on a rural
farmhouse?
What is the significance of this place: "Harbor"?
Why does Look-See come after this family,
and most importantly, what does any of this
have to do with any of Season 1?
These are all questions I'll be answering
on today's episode, but let's start at the
beginning of Season 2 Episode 1.
Our location is New York City and this man,
Robert Capshaw, has just finished taking out
his family and I'm not talking about taking
them out for dinner.
He hears the angry mob outside and finishes
the job by slitting his own throat.
The blood lands on this newspaper article
of Robert and his twin brother, James Capshaw.
The spatter only covers Robert's half of the
photo, telling us that his brother is probably
still alive.
This same trick using the blood to show who's
no longer alive is used again later in the
season on the daughter's drawing of the family.
But why did Robert go crazy on his family?
The answer is in the setting.
As we saw earlier, this scene takes place
in March of 1930.
It looks like the Capshaw Twins opened their
bank in the heat of the Great Economic Depression.
For all you international viewers, not a good
time to open a bank in the USA.
Now the other brother, James Capshaw, took
the dignified approach and got the heck out
of there, he moved his family to this remote
farmhouse.
This is day to night transition is really
cool.
Not only does it remind me of Hereditary...
but instead of using that annoying click noise
that the daughter in Hereditary makes, we
hear one tick from the stopwatch that Look-See
carries around.
Using the stopwatch to show the passage of
time in Look-See?
Very cool.
I couldn't help but think that this next scene
was another homage to a 2018 horror movie.
Was anyone else reminded of A Quiet Place?
So anyway, James Capshaw goes to check things
out at the barn, when he finds a foreclosure
notice from his own bank.
Interesting note here, this stuff at the farmhouse
doesn't take place right after the scene in
New York City.
The date of the foreclosure notice is Monday
August 1st.
The next time August 1st falls on a Monday
after this opening scene, assuming that this
series uses real-world calendars, is August
1932.
So two years go by between this and this.
But it seems that even in these two years,
James hasn't let go of the fact that his business
failed, because as we've seen in previously
in Season 1...
The fact that James's note is written on a
dollar bill is further proof that it's the
bank started by him and his brother that he
was unable to release when he started this
new life in the country.
We never actually get to see what body part
Look-See would have taken from him though,
because our buddy Dead Meat beats him to the
kill, marking probably the first time that
James has added to his own Kill Count.
Which I think might be cheating in a way.
I don't know, I don't make the rules, but
if I went onto a horror movie set and placed
a bunch of Things You Missed around, would
that really be fair?
To add to the mystery in a sense, one of the
thieves gets stabbed by a pitchfork off camera,
and we never see if Look-See is responsible
or not.
I personally don't think he would have gotten
that deep of a stab just from falling on the
fork, but if Look-See is responsible, then
this is the only victim who doesn't receive
a note.
Also, no body part is taken from this victim.
I think this is a new side of Look-See -- like
if you try to interfere with his dealings,
he'll just straight up kill you.
Nightmare on Elm St. anyone?
Before we move on from this first episode,
I think it's important to note that each character's
fatal flaw is setup here in episode 1.
The second episode is about the other thief.
We can see his remorse start to kick in when
blood starts to shed, something he probably
did not sign up for when he agreed to become
a thief.
He finds that his pocket watch has been replaced
by the Look-See watch at the end of episode
1, and the second episode finds him regretting
his actions, having nightmares about his dead
thief buddy (who by the way looks way too
happy to have a pitchfork going through his
torso), and eventually Look-See rips him in
half, which is representative of him getting
half of the share of whatever it was they
were stealing, with the third guy out of the
picture.
The wife, Mary Capshaw, can be seen clutching
her pearls in the first episode, which she
does again in her episode, episode 3.
You can just see her general discomfort being
at the farm house, and her episode's title,
The Second Love, tells me that her love for
her family falls second compared to material
things like her fancy New York apartment,
her necklace and high heels.
She's ultimately given the choice between
her family and her material possessions when
her deceased son appears before her, with
her necklace that was broken in the previous
scene, now fully in tact.
She goes for the necklace first, and as you
can probably imagine, Look-See doesn't like
that, and takes her heart, because her heart
was in the wrong place.
She was in that marriage out of love for money
and material things, not love for her family.
Then we've got the older brother, David Capshaw,
played by my buddy Johnny Berchtold.
He can be seen carrying around this bear,
which formerly belonged to his late little
brother.
I know a lot of people were confused by his
fatal scene, because he eventually does rip
the bear’s head off in an attempt to show
Look-See that he’s not holding onto his
deceased sibling, however, he still does pay
the price.
I would compare this to the the woman letting
go of the ring in the very first episode in
season 1 and, and the father from season 1
who throws away his dead daughter’s birthday
cake.
Despite the fact that these characters are
able to let go of their physical possessions,
they are still targeted, because what Look-See
is looking for is an emotional release, and
David Capshaw never actually has that moment,
so he’s left with his head turned around
180°.
Like the father from Season 1, he is punished
because he’s still looking backwards, not
forwards.
So that covers all of the characters who had
their lives taken by Look-See, but there are
also two characters who survive this time
around: Dead Meat's character Raymond, and
the little girl, Leah Capshaw.
Leah seems to be one who's working with Look-See
this season, leaving the note on the back
of her picture, crossing off the family members
as she takes them out and being the only one
to see Look-See early on and not really look
scared.
I think Leah already had an encounter with
Look-See and she was able to release whatever
it was she was holding in, just like Jenni
was eventually able to do in Season 1, before
becoming Look-See's assistant.
Leah also bears a strong resemblance to the
dead daughter in Season 1 Episode 3, more
on that later.
Then we've got Raymond, who gets his buddy's
blood poured on him.
Carrie anyone?
and Look-See curiously just lets him go.
In order to explore the reason why, I’m
going to refer to James’s recent Kill Count
video on Dead Meat.
Roll it.
"But a deeper look into Raymond's soul, murder
and all, leaves Look-See a little less smiley
than usual, and he drops Raymond to the ground.
Guess this guy didn't have anything to release,
so he takes all of his pieces and walks off
into the woods."
So my analysis of what's happening here is
that Raymond is a sociopath, he doesn't hold
onto anything, so he has nothing to release.
I also think he's most likely going to be
working with Look-See in the future as one
of the assistants, just like Jenni and Leah.
I think the shot where Raymond is first introduced
also kind of suggests that there is some similarity
between him and Look-See.
Also, at the very end of James's Kill Count
video, there's another little clue.
"And of course, huge thanks to CryptTV for
partnering with me for this Kill-Count.
Again make sure you subscribe to them, because
there will be more of me on that channel in
the future."
Just saying, he's probably not making that
up.
But now we can get into the real interesting
Things You Missed -- the clues about the ending.
After a hand comes out of the teddy bear...
Evil Dead 2 anyone?
and Look-See ultimately kills David, the little
sister can finally scratch off the last of
her family members and she returns to Look-See
with the stop-watch.
Then... this happens.
Notice how the new hands are wearing blue
gloves instead of red.
Also, notice if you look at the shadow, this
new Look-See has something attached to its
head.
Let's look back at the original drawing done
by Leah.
You can see the Look-See hiding in the dark,
looming above the Capshaw family.
You can see the Dad, the Mom, the brother,
the sister and the deceased younger brother
with his teddy bear.
But what's this other character hiding in
the dark behind Look-See?
I think that, is the second Look-See.
If the original is made up of the body parts
of those who could not release and wears a
suit, maybe this other version, essentially
the baby Look-See, wears a bow on it's head.
I think the new Look-See will be made up of
the the body parts acquired throughout Season
2.
You can even see that the head is divided
vertically, much like the thief who got torn
in half.
But what happens with this second Look-See
and how does that affect the original Look-See?
I think now is a good time to address the
timeline of events.
Obviously both seasons take place in the past,
but where do they fall chronologically?
We know the exact date of Season 2, but we
don't know exactly when Season 1 takes place.
The episode titles suggest that season 2 takes
place after, like how the first season has
an episode called The Wedding Hand and the
second season has an episode called The Second
Hands.
Or how The Mistress Mind in the first season
has the counterpart, The Second Love in Season
2.
However, I've come to the conclusion that
Season 2, is a prequel.
In rewatching Season 1, I noticed this photo
with a pickup truck in the background.
It looks like a more modern vehicle, and I'm
no car expert, but I looked up what pickup
trucks look like in the 30s and since then,
and came to the conclusion that Season 1 is
more or less modern day.
That's when it all came together for me about
how the two seasons, are related.
The end of Season 2 shows the creation of
the new Look-See, then pulls out and shows
us again, the name of the area they are in:
Harbor.
In Episode 4 of Season 1 thirteen high school
kids are poisoned and die.
If you look at the banners in the background
you'll see the name of the school: Harbor
High.
This is the same area that Look-See ends up
prowling throughout Season 1, which takes
place a 80-90 years later.
The spread out farm houses in the middle of
nowhere eventually become a community.
A high school is built, but Look-See remains
the area all the while to make sure it's citizens
always release their sorrows.
Remember how I said Leah looks a lot like
the guy's daughter in Season 1 Episode 3?
They aren't the same person, or the same actress,
but I would theorize that girl and her father
are descendants of Leah Capshaw.
So the big question becomes: what happens
to the second Look-See with the blue gloves?
Well, you better subscribe to CryptTV to find
out in the next season of Look-See.
And of course you'll be treated to more scary
short films every Tuesday, Thursday and Friday.
In addition to their three videos a week,
CryptTV releases limited edition merch, like
this awesome Look-See shirt I’m wearing
right now.
If you want a chance to get your own, just
sign up for the Crypt newsletter and you’ll
be the first to hear about new designs.
I’ll leave a link in the description if
you’re interested.
Next video, I'll be discussing Sunny Family
Cult and the origin of Look-See.
Tap or click the video on the left to go back and rewatch all of Look-See Season 2
so you can let me know what I missed in the comments. Or watch my Things You MIssed on
the first season of Look-See by going to the video on the right.
Until then I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.